good afternoon and welcome to this forum
entitled the Arab uprisings of view from
the University on Tahrir Square it's my
happy task to welcome Lisa Anderson now
president of the American University of
Cairo back to the school that she did so
much to build welcome today's event is
co-sponsored by SEPA and the political
science student association it will
address the dramatic events of the last
two months three months and we're
especially privileged to have with us an
observer who knows more about Tunisia
Libya and Egypt than almost anyone else
I know so with that let me turn the
program over to Professor Jack Snyder
who will introduce our speakers well
this is a real pleasure to be able to
invite you back to speak at this podium
that you've stood before on many
occasions and to have in the audience
both of your constituencies Lisa
Anderson was the former chair of the
political science department and also
the former dean of sefa and we've
arranged it so that the audience is both
political science undergrads and some
political science faculty but also
steepest students so your folks are
welcoming you home and I'm gonna get out
of the way quickly because you indeed
wrote the book on Libyan state building
and now can tell us about the the Libyan
state unraveling and I remember when you
were were working on democratization in
the Arab world before there was any of
now so this must be very gratifying to
you before you start I want to invite up
to the podium need of a Dudus who's the
president of the political science
Students Association to just welcome you
to the undergraduate constituency here
yeah hello and thank you for joining us
on behalf of all the students here I'm
honored to be able to welcome you this
afternoon president Anderson you not
only just lived through a national
revolution but you did so while
overseeing a world were now into college
campus at the center of the movement
your students no older than those in
this room catalyzed Egypt's fight for
freedom and our diet energized by desire
honed in your classrooms to reclaim
their country from despotism we are
honored that you're here today to give
us just a tiny glimpse of this
historical moment the same one that kept
us here thousands of miles away glued to
our TVs for weeks
president Anderson I warmly thank you
for coming and students I look forward
to seeing many of you at the reception
that will follow what will undoubtedly
be an incredibly memorable speech and
discussion thank you again
thank you very much thank you for the
invitation thank you for the opportunity
thank you for your patience while I was
late
actually in deference to the invitation
and audience this is going to be a
little political science II there are
fabulous stories and I'm happy to tell
some of those stories about a UC alumni
faculty students who played important
roles in the events in Tahrir Square who
were some of the best commentators on
the events as they took place who helped
manage the relations between the
protesters and the government I can tell
you what it's like to run an institution
that discovers their snipers on the roof
of the building of shooting at the
protesters what it's like to manage an
institution during an Internet blackout
that no one in the world expected and so
forth and most importantly probably some
of what it's like to have free
expression in a context where for at
least 30 years and maybe forever there
hasn't been something like that so I'm
looking forward to your questions and
looking forward to the conversation but
I wanted first a few remarks they
actually follow up on a lecture that I
gave here at SEPA in the fall that was
called the policy of the politics of
policymaking in non democratic settings
and it was for pop as it's known to its
friends at SEPA and in a sense it's an
interesting moment because of course I'm
moving from I hope an environment of a
non democratic setting to a
democratizing setting and the politics
of policymaking are getting all the more
complicated and confused but in
interesting and important sorts of ways
ways that I think do reflect both on how
we as political scientists think and how
we as prospective policymakers think so
you will forgive me if I indulge a
little bit in thinking about how these
revolutions or uprisings
reflect on the literature and the
practice of politics for a few minutes
and then obviously we can go back to the
stories if you want and I want to make
two basic points several one of which I
have made repeatedly here in this
building so you'll have to listen to it
one more time and another which is
subsidiary to that non democratic or
authoritarian as a category of regime
type is residual you can tell just by
the word it is anything that is not
democratic which can be a great variety
of things and it's hard therefore to
find patterns in policymaking if what
you're talking about is everything that
isn't something else and that may not
matter very much as one thinks about the
trajectory of the development of
politics over time in the contemporary
world if you think that democracy is the
future anyway in other words if this is
all going to be left in the dust and it
doesn't really matter what the politics
of policymaking and Don non-democratic
circumstances are because everything is
ultimately going to become democratic
anyway then you sort of think well you
know Lisa that's a fine distinction but
who cares but I actually think it is
important because it tells us that that
is to say thinking about whether there
are patterns in non-democratic regimes
is important because it shapes the
pattern of breakdown and the prospects
for various kinds of posts breakdown
regimes okay I finished the real
political science II party non
democratic policymaking environments do
seem to me however to have certain kind
of patterns to them that are worthwhile
thinking about as we look at Egypt and
Libya and Tunisia in the first place one
of the things that characterizes all of
these countries and I would argue most
non democratic settings is that
information is scarce so as you think
about these countries on the eve of the
uprisings which has riveted us all in
none of these countries but in different
ways I will
you was information easily available to
the general populace but the character
of scarcity of information can be quite
varied information may exist somewhere
in the system but not be shared in other
words there may be information that's
available to the national intelligence
authorities but to no one else
it may not exist at all it may not be
collected in the first place one of the
things that struck me when I first got
to Egypt is that this is a country that
has one of the highest per capita rates
of car accidents traffic accidents in
the world and very little data is
reported on that because if there isn't
a death there's nothing to report that
means that there's a certain kind of
information that's just simply not
collected it could be collected but it's
not so it doesn't in that sense exist so
you have the kind of information that
exists and isn't shared then you have
the kind of information that isn't
collected and therefore sort of doesn't
exist and either way and I think it does
matter but either way you get the
proliferation of rumor innuendo
conspiracy theories of various kinds
because there's no way of verifying any
of these sorts of claims that is
something that after a revolution is
very hard to manage because there are
conspiracy theories innuendo and rumors
all all around both during and after the
revolution that are very hard to verify
and people aren't accustomed to being
asked to verify the claims that they
make so that's one of the things that
characterizes democratic decision-making
the availability of information and also
then discussion and debate about that
information both discussion and debate
in non democratic settings are typically
relatively restricted and perhaps as a
result of that the absence of reliable
information is not as noticeable as it
might be since if you can't talk about
it you don't talk about what you don't
have political actors who know they will
never be held accountable however
because they will either never take
power or will never lose power can say
anything they want
so discussion and debate
it's not actually what we would think of
as discussion is and debate it's simply
making claims that will never be tested
or at least the people who are making
the claims think they it will never be
tested so you can go around saying
things like Islam is the solution and no
one will ever figure out whether that's
true or not or the National Democratic
Party is democratic and no one will ever
actually test that proposition or my
opponents or cockroaches something that
Gaddafi said this last week and of
course that will probably be tested but
you can make those kinds of claims
because it's not really a debate it's
not really a discussion it's just saying
things and since no one will ever be
contesting in an electoral process or in
a policy process some of these sorts of
claims people can make any kinds of
claims they want political action is
also restricted to authorized vehicles
groups and institutions this combined
with the widely the lack of widely
disseminated information tends to
produce several consequences one of
which is corruption because of course
all of us who want something from our
system need proximity to those with
access and in the absence of wide and
well publicized information that kind of
thing can be manipulated in certain
sorts of ways but there are different
kinds of corruption a question to which
I will return shortly when I talk about
the differences between Egypt Libya and
Tunisia on the eve of their revolutions
there's also an absence of a loyal
opposition opposition is viewed as
intrinsically and inherently disloyal
and it's very hard in fact one of the
things that I had a lot of difficulty
doing when I first got to Cairo was
talking to people about the simple idea
of a loyal opposition either you were
inside the ruling party or you were
intrinsically disloyal and a corollary
of that is most anti-government activity
is construed as outside the framework of
the authorized and therefore
basically treachery so you have a very
limited realm of permissible debate the
as partly as a result of all of these
kind of characteristics legislators are
relatively weak produced by appointment
or by elections that are understood to
be rigged they tend to rubber-stamp
executive branch initiatives rather than
produce proposals born of popular demand
because nobody knows what the populace
would demand were it permitted to demand
anything and you also have what are
often called in the literature soft
budget constraints if the boss wants it
will find the money for it
particularly since we don't know how
much it's going to cost anyway since we
don't have accurate information so there
tends to be starting of projects because
the boss the president whoever it is
wants the project and then it turns out
of course you didn't have the money for
it so it's never finished and those of
you who have traveled in these kinds of
countries will see all of the unfinished
projects that have proliferated because
nobody actually calculated whether it
was something desired by its putative
constituents or something that anyone
could afford finally sort of running
through the cycle of how you make
demands you discuss them you think about
legislation you think about you know
implementing the legislation there are a
lot of laws passed regulations issues
project started which are flatted
ignored and never finished there is not
the feedback through the loop in that
that we would think of as a conventional
policymaking process and compliance is
not born of acquiescence much less
understanding so much as by a born of
intimidation and fear or at least
resignation and one of the things that
characterized all three of these
countries before their revolutions and
it was quite striking and I actually
wrote something about this about Libya
about four or five years ago but it was
also true in Egypt there was a lot of
weapons of the weak behavior in
populations that felt they were obliged
to comply but didn't really want to and
one
of the most striking of these was
garbage people would throw garbage in
the streets and it was a kind of
contempt it was a and then the
government's wouldn't arrange to have it
picked up so it was mutual contempt and
Lybia which is one of the richest
countries per capita in the world is
also one of the filthiest
because there is this mutual contempt of
garbage strewn in the streets and the
government refusing to pick it up and at
first that seemed very Libya but then it
turns out that the one of the
post-revolutionary most striking
phenomenon of the post Revolutionary era
in Egypt is the extent to which everyone
is picking up garbage everywhere Tahrir
Square you could eat off the stones of
Tahrir Square it is so clean this
business about cleanliness corruption
garbage contempt dignity it is of a
piece it is weapons of the weak it is
the way people express themselves in
circumstances in which they can't
express themselves and it's really quite
striking so I think one of the things
that that one sees in across these three
revolutions or the extent to which the
contempt conveyed by regimes indifferent
to their people they know very little
about and do even less for led to
uprisings that were really about dignity
that was the rhetoric that's the way
they talked about it and we can talk
about the sort of political economy of
these uprisings but it is quite striking
the extent to which the rhetoric and the
the mobilization were around issues of
just being treated with respect and
often unemployment was described in
those terms
police brutality was described in those
terms lack of access to information was
described in those terms why do we have
to have a government that doesn't treat
us with respect and there there were
other ways of approaching this on other
underlying issues but it all wrapped
itself up as the spark went from Tunis
to Egypt to Libya being in in
fundamental ways about
tired of having governments that didn't
treat the citizens with respect they
were so the patterns though were
different you had these themes you had
these aging autocrats you had
authoritarian regimes that were that the
people had gotten very very tired of
that had lost any of their sort of
ideological legitimacy decades ago and
so forth
and at some point people said they'd had
it and the interesting question of at
what point do people decide they've had
it I think remains a big political
science question but the rollin how the
the revolutions themselves are the
uprising themselves took place reflected
differences in the character of each of
these regimes in Tunisia for example
information was very very tightly
regulated it was an Orwellian
circumstance where the Tunisians
constantly described particularly for
international audiences this
middle-income developing country that
whose numbers were really terrific they
hosted one of the UN information new
information technologies for a couple of
years ago at exactly at precisely the
time when all of the new social media
were being ruthlessly repressed and in a
sense it was dishonesty taken to an art
there was very little discussion and
debate very high levels of repression of
opposition or even questioning of the
regime policies and there was a very
characteristic kind of corruption which
was different from the corruption of
egypt and libya so when you talk about
corruption and the politics of
corruption I do think that there are
differences that make that there are
characteristic kinds of corruption that
make a difference in politics in Tunisia
the corruption was at the top it was the
president his wife and their relatives
and they were known as the family and
everybody in Tunisia knew about the
family and that
somebody in the family and keep in mind
that the president had seven siblings
and the president's wife had ten
siblings so it was a big family and they
all got a cut of everything and that's
how corruption worked in Tunisia at the
local level administrated ministration
was relatively technocratic relatively
highly educated poorly served by this
central administration or a central
government that was corrupt
it was as if it was being run by a but a
country that was being run by a sort of
a ring of thieves and it was humiliating
but it wasn't the kind of corruption
that got to small scale bribes
everywhere throughout the entire country
there was very little genuine law and
regulation the families had a very bad
example for that kind of thing and
compliance was grudging and resentful
interestingly the revolts started in the
hinterlands and spiraled toward the
center this is a very different dynamic
than was the case in Egypt as we will
shortly see and they were joined by long
repressed but still fairly well
organized labor unions
so today the debates about a successor
regime reflect the fact that the middle
to lower level administrative capacity
in Tunisia is still relatively strong
that the army did not support the
government but refused to rule and there
is the prospect of a loyal opposition in
the labor movement among others
relatively straitened resources the
country relies for example heavily on
tourism a hardened budget constraints
and contribute to demands for
information so there's a set of dynamics
there which are not perfect but are
relatively auspicious for democratic
politics in Egypt the highly disciplined
youth movement that demonstrated its
capabilities in Tahrir Square showed the
value of being prepared these were the
Boy Scouts if you will of the Arab world
they didn't know when their chance would
come but they weren't going to miss it
it did come and they were well prepared
for the kind of mobilization that you
saw realized in the movements no one
I think least of all the organizers
thought that this would actually lead to
the ouster of the regime but they were
prepared when the opportunity presented
itself they had also a legacy of more
information that had been available to
their peers in Tunisia the press and
media were less restricted in Egypt than
they had been in Tunisia although I must
say the closing of the internet for four
days did restrict information quite
considerably for a little while but in
general the youth in the young people in
Egypt are fairly well networked and the
issues that they confronted were clearer
than was the case in Tunisia the
authoritarianism in Egypt I would argue
was more negligent than predatory and
again I think that matters you hear
accusations of high-level corruption in
Egypt today about the old regime but by
the standards of the Tunisian corruption
at high levels it was relatively benign
implicate but but the implications of
policies about which there was little or
no formal or effective feedback created
small-scale corruption on a massive
scale everything in Egypt is formerly
very cheap and actually very expensive
because everybody has to pay extra for
whatever it is they want including
police protection or education or
anything so that's going to actually
make the reform of the system
considerably more difficult if it is a
thoroughgoing reform than would be the
case will be the case in Tunisia the
effects of that kind of neglect may be
harder to reverse than broom moving the
family in Tunisia because hundreds of
thousands of teachers and police
officers will have to be will probably
have to be retrained to do their jobs
the way one would expect teachers and
police officers to do them but the
military had been largely isolated from
that not neglected as you can well
imagine and has been playing a strong
role in the transition but debate on the
future of the safe and clean
position of the post-revolutionary
movements suggest that there may well be
a loyal opposition that comes out of
Tahrir Square the interesting we can
talk more about the how one interprets
the yes vote in the Egypt referendum
yesterday but I think it's quite clear
that it is if nothing else an
endorsement of the military's plans for
a quick transition and departure from
power in Libya finally you saw a ragtag
band of rebels mostly but not
exclusively from the eastern provinces
where opposition had been endemic to
Gadhafi for the last 30 years you can
tell that there's no information
available in Libya because there nope
there's not even any coordination among
the protesters they had been very little
discussion and debate in Libya although
the last several years had seen a bit
more thanks to cyclist Slama Gadhafi the
rulers son but there's no legislature no
budget debates no real law regulation no
compliance and no feedback Gaddafi lives
inside his revolution as has become
apparent to all and the revolution was
deliberately designed to prevent the
growth of bureaucracy professional
middle classes nationwide networks of
economic ties civic organizations and
political institutions so you now have a
country without any of those things
corruption here was neither a family nor
bureaucrats who needed to supplement
their paltry income but the last of last
resort of people in the face of induced
scarcity and very few people in the
country did not partake in some measure
or other of something that they would
probably themselves describe as corrupt
in order to get the necessities of life
hence the reliance as a last resort on
family and clan and much of the
discussion of tribalism in Libya I want
to argue to you is actually a discussion
of an induced tribalism these are
reinforced ties in the absence of any
alternative identity or organizational
structure all of this makes the
the post-qaddafi reconstruction far more
about state formation than it does about
democratic transition it's quite clear
that what's going to have to happen in
Libya first is the remitting together of
a polity and a state before any kind of
regime discussion can take place so in
some what I want to argue to those of
you who are thinking think you think
about politics political science and
policymaking there are different kinds
of non democratic settings and it
behooves us to disaggregate them if we
want to understand their impact on
transitions and on successor regimes so
even if what we really care a part care
about in our heart of hearts is
democracy it is going to be achieved
from different directions at different
paces and in different ways depending in
part on what the starting point is the
availability of information the levels
of permissible debate the character of
legislation the character of the budget
constraints all of these kinds of things
are different from one non democratic
setting to another and it is therefore
not surprising that the consequences of
those are different one of the I'll
leave you with a sort of what I think is
a relatively elegant indicator of the
different consequences for each of these
three countries of these differences and
the kind of differences in the
post-revolutionary projects note that
Ben Ali in Tunisia was exiled from the
country Mubarak was permitted to stay
home he's in internal exile he's in his
palace in Sharma Sheikh and Gaddafi is
very likely to die rather than be either
permitted to leave the country or to
enjoy internal exile and that tells you
something I think quite evocative about
the different characters of these
regimes and they're the popular view of
them
Mubarak by the time he was ousted was
clearly someone that the Egyptian people
were tired of but they weren't so angry
with him
that they made him leave the country or
worse yet killed him but I think you
will see good every meeting that kind of
fate because that's how angry people are
and on that note I want to stop and
invite any questions you have both
policy political science what happened
today you see the floor is open thank
you very much
so we're gonna ask you to line up at the
mic in the center of the room to ask
your question and while people are
lining up I'm gonna grab the first
question myself you you mentioned the
the vote signaling possibly that the
Egyptian people are in favor of a very
rapid pace of the transition to get the
military off the stage which is what
some of the Columbia faculty who were at
this very podium said a couple of weeks
ago would be desirable but I just
noticed that over the weekend the two
political groupings in Egypt that were
most enthusiastic about a really rapid
transition are the former governing
governing party and the Muslim
Brotherhood who are already well
organized and apparently think they will
profit from a speedy transition whereas
the urban liberal or whatever you want
to call them demonstrators have been
saying well we need more time there like
hundreds of us that want to run for
office and we haven't formed ourselves
into a political party and if we have to
run in single-member districts with
first-past-the-post we'll never get any
seats and that all the seats will be won
by the two organized parties so is there
an argument for going slower rather than
faster well most of the faculty and
students at AUC voted no so of course
there's an argument there were that
group of people the intellectual elite
the well particularly well educated and
so forth and so I do want more time they
do want more time to think about the
Constitution to think about the
electoral system to organize themselves
and so forth and it is quite clear that
you know more than 20% of the people
feel that way but there were two
problems it was partly
that that is a set of intellectual
elites that most of the rest of the
country doesn't necessarily have a lot
of patience for so even though they did
lead the revolution and everybody
thought that was terrific
thank you very much that's pretty much
what intellectual elites do but the
other but the other problem was it was
this question of if you voted no what
would the consequences of that be this
is a country that right now is in the
midst of a considerable sort of
existential insecurity and anxiety
everything has changed the police have
disappeared from the streets we don't
even you know there's kind of no
president who's in charge here the
Supreme Military Council and so forth
and so on so there's a lot of sense of
it feels like it's been a decade since
the beginning of the year if you vote no
you don't know what the consequences of
that are gonna be the military did not
say a yes vote goes this way a no go
vote goes that way they said a yes vote
goes this way so for a lot of people it
was sort of saying I'm gonna vote for
something that I can see a predictable
path I don't see any real terrible costs
to it there is another point at which
the Constitution can be revisited we
don't necessarily want the military to
rule for a long time if we vote no does
that mean a military rule are they going
to get comfortable in office we don't
want that to happen
so even some of the tucker square
liberal intellectual elite said well you
know wait a minute we run the risk of a
no vote and they say okay we'll sit here
for five years while you guys get
yourself organized which nobody wants so
it was a complicated it was not you know
the the reasons for voting yes or no
were not self-evident and I think one of
the interesting things and this was true
I remember when when the first contest
of elections in Mexico and all of these
leftist voted for Fox but not because
they endorsed his platform but because
they wanted to say they saw an
alternation in power and you saw some of
that kind of calculating here of people
who were voting for something not
because they actually thought it was the
better outcome but they were thinking to
themselves sort of tactic
what does this mean so there was both
principled voting and tactical voting in
I would say the sort of you know 35% or
40% who are the educated elite the
people who led the revolution who
endorsed the revolution and so forth and
then of course in the countryside it is
true that most people are just more
comfortable with something fairly stable
and well-known and so forth which is
either the Muslim Brotherhood or the NDP
or you know whatever the military told
us to and the wonderful thing is that
everybody in Egypt has been getting text
messages from the Supreme Military
Council telling them you know please
behave go back to work
vote yes so some people do that
thank you very much first of all for
joining us I have a question actually
about an article that you wrote and had
published in Bloomberg News about a week
or two ago which I conveniently am able
to quote right now you wrote you wrote
neither the u.s. nor the international
community you're talking about Libya
should be deterred by the difficulty of
imagining the aftermath from fulfilling
their responsibilities to protect
citizens from the D predations of
vicious governments in fact they should
plan for it any military diplomatic
intervention that will bring an end to
the Qadhafi regime should be accompanied
from the beginning by mobilization of
the resources for political
reconstruction you go on to lists or
mention a couple of international
organizations and agencies which could
contribute to this kind of
reconstruction so I have a two-part
question I guess first of all should we
read your comments to imply that there
is a human right to democracy and that
this human rights should be able to
should be enforceable by the
international community should a
consensus arise upon an instance where
there is a violation and secondly are
you perhaps concerned that this produces
a kind of paternalism that first of all
demeans the political agency of
undemocratic peoples and secondly as one
of the political theorists in this
Herman has written denies the
opportunity to engage in the the tumults
and the the debates where you you learn
how to compromise and construct a
government and write your own laws I was
a this was a this is a complicated
moment for those of us who want to think
about on the one hand what has become
known in UN circles as this sort of
responsibility to protect there is
increasingly a doctrine that I think is
hard not to subscribe to at least in the
abstract that you know brutal
governments should not be permitted to
kill their own citizens with impunity
that just you know that's very 20th
century we're not going to do that
anymore on the other hand it's hard to
know how to organize that in a way that
does not begin to pull the rug out from
under in this instance the insurgents it
is the insurgents insurgency it's not
and it should not be construed as an
insurgency from outside the country and
so forth and ultimately I think the
reason why the Arab League apart from
the fact that everybody hates Gaddafi
the reason why the Arab League did come
around to endorsing a no-fly zone it so
forth and so on was a sense that the
incredible dynamism enthusiasm of the
uprisings in Tunisia and Egypt they
themselves would be undermined if the
comparable uprising in Libya were
brutally repressed
and certainly in Egypt there is that
kind of sentiment that different as the
circumstances are nobody wanted to see
that snuffed out that it was the same
call for dignity it was the same sense
that here's an opportunity to really see
the people express their desire for a
better life a better polity and so forth
it's on and nobody wanted that to be
destroyed so how do you balance
on the one hand this international level
kind of responsibility to protect which
does have a somewhat paternalistic
quality to it one to this enthusiasm for
supporting and insurgency that is a
homegrown insurgency and three the
really genuine concern which I think now
is becoming an increasing concern in my
estimation that the what was described
as a no-fly zone is in fact becoming an
effort to kill Qaddafi which is not what
and so the Arab League is backing off
that was not what anyone's intent was
and I think that that then becomes yet
another sort of you know invasion of a
country which is what nobody wanted the
outcome to be if I may you you
emphasized in that article the idea that
and in the passage that I read
particularly that democratic
institutions the process of building
those should be something that the
Allies or the international community
takes into consideration this is before
this is Mart you wrote this March six or
something like that and you emphasize
the idea that democracy building more or
less needed to be and should be if I
read you correctly something that the
international community the UN took into
consideration now you know to me it's
hard to marry that to some of what you
were just saying about you know limited
nature of what needs to be done in the
sense of respecting and indigenous okay
perhaps what the confusion here is is
that I don't think the issue in Libya
after you know the guns stop is gonna be
democracy the at issue there is going to
be State Building it's gonna be very
elemental do you want the eastern
province to say in the country or not
and you have to be able to have a
conversation about that is this country
going to end up the same shape as it was
for the last 90 years
who's having that conversation and whose
decision is that well somebody needs it
seems to me one could have it implode
into fighting which is what I worry
about I think there's gonna be a lot of
score settling there's a lot of
resentment there's a lot of you know a
lot of bad things happen to people in
the last 40 years and either that
implodes into continuing fighting or
there is some kind of mechanism for
saying we need to have that conversation
without the fighting that there should
be a civil way to debate those sorts of
questions about how positions in a new
government are going to be allocated
about how people get administrative
posts in fact how an administration is
rebuilt about how one has a military
apparatus or not about what kinds of
basic regulations for a market there
should be those kinds of conversations
will need to take place in Libya we
could say hands-off this is Somalia it's
their business if they just want to you
know sort of spend the next 20 years
shooting each other we that's one option
or we could say there are increasing
numbers and characters of civil society
organizations globally that might be
deployed you see this sometimes cently
the most what you see in the news the
most often is these effort by the elders
for example in Africa to take people
with experience of government in saying
there must be a better way that to do
this than just fight with each other and
it seems to me that some of those kinds
of mechanisms might be constructively
deployed to help the Libyans have that
conversation among themselves it's not
imposing a solution it's simply saying
if there's a way to do this without
killing each other that would probably
be better
actually Mike Mike Wesch original
question was a follow-up on the first
one and all I'll have a follow-up on
that one as well
okay with regard to organization I'm
wondering about the on the ground
realities in terms of organization you
you had mentioned those who led led the
the protests and from some of the
conversations that were going on in the
last couple weeks before break there was
a lot of talk about they're not really
being a leader or any or any set of
leaders that this was a very you know
group you know process and so I'm
wondering are there are their leaders
emerging or their organization occurring
what kind of organization and what do
you see for the future of that and in
regard to talks do you see there being
an ability to in Libya do you see there
being a possibility for talks it sounds
like the rebels want Qaddafi gone and
Gaddafi isn't gonna go so is there do
you see there being a possibility for
space to actually have any kind of
conversation without Qaddafi being there
or with coffee being there no no let me
start with that know when I talk about
needing to have a set of conversations
about what Libya is gonna look like and
this is predicated on Gaddafi's
departure but that's the problem right
that he did spend 40 years disorganizing
everybody deliberately that was a
constant revolution that was the design
of the whole operation so that means
that you have groups of people who have
not had routinize regular civil
conversations with each other about any
of these kinds of issues for decades
somebody has to convene that it may be
that the Libyans themselves are going to
be able to convene that but given how
angry they are at each other for those
who collaborated and those who
collaborated 20 years ago and stopped
collaborating and changed sides and then
change sides again I mean look what's
been happening
the last several weeks whole groups of
people have changed sites several times
and that's a reflection of how difficult
it is going to be for people to sit down
and say this is what I really believe in
so much of what Gaddafi created was a
society of opportunism because how else
would you get what you needed that it is
going to be in fact very hard in his
absence and I anticipate that whatever
happens in Libya going forward will be
in his absence it will be very hard to
convene those kinds of conversations
without a lot of that score settling
resentment and anger and you know I
remember you I remember your father I
remem you know can we do this in a way
that doesn't bring all of that to the
surface and doesn't bring it all to the
surface in a violent way because Gaddafi
regime was very violent
so a lot of that is I remember when you
were there when my father was hung so
that's how mad I am
maybe maybe which just has to you know
burn itself out or maybe there's a way
to say no it doesn't have to burn itself
out let us see whether we can organize
these conversations such that people can
express some of that but don't it
doesn't disintegrate into it and that's
the concern I have is that there are
deep deep deep anger and resentment in
that country much of it understandable
but also much of it going to be very
hard to manage in a Reconstruction
period so that's the Libya question I
think you're the first part of the
question was more about Egypt Egypt yeah
I think the thing that was most striking
about the early days of the mobilization
in Tahrir Square is that in fact there
were several handfuls of youth April 6
movement some people who had organized
protests against the government
repeatedly in the past who were prepared
to continue to do that and realized that
a conjunction of circumstances including
their own learning about effective
mobilization effective organizing they
who were mostly well-educated young
people did go into poor neighborhoods
get different kinds of a much more mass
mobilization to go into Tahrir Square
than had been the case in earlier
efforts to mobilize cross-class cross
neighborhood cross you know different
kinds of cleavages in society so they've
by then they were very sophisticated
about how they would mobilize I think
they themselves were surprised at how
successful this was they themselves
thought got more people into Tahrir
Square than they expected and they
themselves wanted to be not invisible
but wanted this to be a reflection of
the people of Egypt they didn't want it
to be something where they took credit
for it or they took responsibility for
it so they deliberately downplayed their
own role but increasingly you are
beginning to see in the youth of the
revolution movement their discussions
these are the people who refuse to meet
Secretary Clinton okay so there are
groups of people young people who were
instrumental in organizing and managing
this astonishingly well disciplined
civil disobedience for 18 days and they
are gonna play an important role in the
construction of political parties in the
construction of debates about electoral
systems and so forth and so on so but
they don't want to be precisely because
they think and I think collectively they
think and I think they're right about
this that there has been too much focus
on the single leader you know it's
always been about Nasser or Sadat or
Mubarak or I'm remove so or Obata die or
somebody like that and they would really
like to have it be about ideas about
institutions insofar as they can so
they're deliberately backpedaling
themselves as individuals now how long
that would last once parties get formed
if candidates have to run for office and
so forth remains to be seen but but
there are people and they are by my
lights astonishingly tactically
sophisticated very clever making making
real their principles in their behavior
and how they operate
mrs. president what about the the the
contagion and what about Bahrain and
Yemen and there have been some incidents
in in Syria as well and which is the the
next rotten fruit to fall that's the
$64,000 question I one of the things
this is another reason why I have to say
even though I was and remained skittish
about the intervention in Libya I think
had there been no intervention in Libya
no other fruit would fall that people
were really looking to if Gaddafi was if
you will permitted to extinguish the
uprising in Libya everyone else would be
permitted to do the same thing and the
fact that there has been this if you
will international declaration that such
uprisings should be permitted to you
know see an end has empowered yet again
I mean they you know you see it in Yemen
you see it in in particularly I think
Yemen these days but you've seen it pop
up and then disappear and pop up and
disappear in some other places so I do
think that there's if Gadhafi does fall
in Libya you will probably see a few
other of these kinds of rulers fall
Yemen is a plausible case the problem
with Yemen is that it looks more like
Libya in being a relatively disorganized
and relatively difficult place to
construct a new polity in but it's not
quite as disorganized as Libya is I
think the Saudis are in in a very
ticklish position in Bahrain I must say
and I'm eager to watch how that develops
I don't want to but talking about behind
you one cannot fail to notice like the
dual standards that
are applied to the the for the tyrant
but friends to and to tyrants but
historic enemies like like Qaddafi
what's your opinion well those of us
that have worked on this region for a
long time are so used to noticing dual
standards that we don't notice them
anymore but yes you're right
following the vote the UN Security
Council vote to implement the no-fly
zone the British and French and the u.s.
they were quick to act and that came
also that enforcement with 110 Tomahawk
missiles and cruise missiles and
understanding I mean the point was
probably a lot more genuine but on the
eighth year anniversary of the US
invasion of Iraq do you still feel like
in the Arab world and the greater world
there is still I mean understanding the
situation's are very different there is
a level of uneasiness with this type of
intervention with missiles falling like
this oh I completely agree with that I
don't I mean that the problem is that I
think what people including me advocated
was was a much lighter touch than
appears to be the case and whether
that's because we simply can't do it any
other way or because we did in fact see
this as an opportunity to do something
which we shouldn't have done I don't
know yet but it does seem to be much
more heavy-handed much more damaging to
the civilians that we say we're
protecting then would have been the
intent and as I say it's one of the
reasons why the Arab League is moving
back very quickly and I completely
sympathize with that could you say more
about the limited participation we
should understand that well I think I
mean part of it is keep in mind look
Egypt and Tunisia or distracted as they
should be I mean we don't necessarily
want them to get caught in a Maelstrom
of Libya while they're thinking about
their domestic issues which and that was
one of the worries is that it would
become a distraction for countries which
if they do things right now have real
opportunities at home to manage a new
political structure and system so let's
not have them be you know frontline in
Libya so there's that kind of then I
think there is a perhaps more you know
who do you want what you know what names
do you want painted on the side of the
planes if it was Saudi planes it would
still be the military of the United
States for all intents and purposes with
the Saudi flag painted on the side of
the plane so I mean my view is that that
the Mike Mike if you will immediate
concern here is not to get particularly
the Egyptians drawn into this because
Egypt if Egypt works well this is eighty
million people and it would be
profoundly valuable to have a working
transition in Egypt even if it came at
the cost of a little bit more difficulty
in Libya than would have been the case
of the and that would have been
complicated anyway for the Egyptians to
take a front line position in Libya
would have complicated Libya would have
complicated Egypt anyway so forth end to
no real good end so so my view is that
it does make sense to have the Arab
militaries take a back seat in part
because of the relative prominence of
Egypt anyway I know that very few is
mention about the international
interests in Egypt on how its managed
during that phase like in Libya is very
easy to like at least one can like see
what's happening there I see the
international interest in there and how
it plays
what about Egypt so like the military is
it's obvious that it didn't have and
still doesn't have it's in its form when
it comes to a foreign policy wasn't in
line with Mubarak's regime so it was
apparent as soon as work step down that
were onion-shaped were allowed to the
Suez Canal to send some sort of a
message so how do you think that is
playing inside because no one is
mentioning about it
like for example Omar Suleiman the head
of intelligence he disappeared from the
stage he is someone who used to maintain
the Mubarak interest when it comes to
foreign policy regional policy
israel-palestine everything how is it
playing inside and how's the pressure is
playing in is the military and how do
you see that's playing well the
interesting thing is that you're quite
right that the debates within Egypt
today are not about foreign policy at
all
I almost surprisingly so it's not about
the United States it's not about Mubarak
relationship with the United States it's
not about Israel it's not about Iran
it's about domestic politics and over
the course of time I have to assume that
foreign policy issues will come to the
fore more than they have over the course
of the last six weeks or so but they
really have not been important issues in
the way people talk about the players
within Egypt so you're right I don't
think that that's something that the you
know when the when people talk about you
know it was clear that Clinton when she
came to Egypt got a very lukewarm
reception the youth of the revolution
wouldn't meet her and so forth and so on
so there's a little bit of arm's length
with the United States but beyond that
there's relatively little discussion of
it so it's hard to tell what that will
look like over the long term
you don't see that there's any other
forces inside Egypt playing internet in
the internet front maintaining against
against the interest the foreign
interests of the military so the
military has certain foreign interests
do don't you don't think that there's
any force inside the Egyptian society
like acting for the other side not yet
not now no I mean the military is in a
funny kind of position keep in mind that
again in contrast to the Tunisian
military the Egyptian military actually
had combat experience and that has had
two effects one of which is that it
continues to have a sort of residual
hero's and patriotism and so forth aura
about it but it also means that it has a
a fairly clear sense of its mission it
does not want a rule now if it sits
there for a long time it may change its
mind but
right now it sees itself as the defender
of the country and so forth and so on
and it has relatively good standing in
that role within Egypt that's not
something that people dispute very much
they don't want it to rule they know it
doesn't want to rule they think it did a
reasonably good job defending the
country and so forth and so on so all of
that's relatively stable and in fact the
fact that it has a substantial kind of
economic presence or presence in the
economy is something that it's probably
going to be protected in the context of
the debates over democracy and so forth
over the next few years of the things
that people are going to be debating the
enterprises owned by the military
probably are not going to be on the
first are not going to be in the first
at the beginning of the list so I think
it's reasonably protected there's not a
lot of unhappiness
within Egypt at this juncture over the
military and its role in politics or in
Egyptian foreign policy hi president
Anderson I was just was just wondering
if you could tell us any stories about
AUC during the revolution and because
they sound like you probably have some
pretty interesting stories to tell and
all but also what the impact of the
revolution will now have on how you run
a UC yeah I don't know whether actually
understand Andrew all right a couple of
revolutions are very uncomfortable
things so we we love them we who are you
know Americans in the American
Revolution everything but actually
living through them are kind of
complicated and difficult sometimes and
I'll give you one story about that and
then I'll give you a story or two about
the impact of the revolution on AUC as
you all may recall on January 28 that
was the height of the violence in Tahrir
Square and at that time the campus that
is right on top red square which had
been closed for several days was
attacked and there were people it was
the security was breached and there was
some real hot fighting on the campus
what we were told by our own security
people was that the protesters wanted to
go through the campus to get to the
interior ministry and it is a shortcut
to get from Tahrir Square to the
interior ministry you can go straight
through the campus and that as they
broke down the gate in front of the main
building on the campus the security
forces came in the other direction to
stop them and then there was a lot of
fighting in what we call the palace
building which is the main old building
from before the late 19th century when
by the time I got there which is about
two and a half days later there was lots
of broken glass all over the place a lot
of the offices had been looted in that
building there was blood all over the
staircase there was blood on the roof
there was broken things you know
crenellations and so forth had been
broken evidence in other words of a lot
of fighting and battling and so forth
and so on the security our security told
us that took about four hours for them
to get everybody out of the campus and
to risa cure the campus and they showed
us the tear gas canisters that had been
logged into the campus all of which I
should point out say made in the United
States and all of which are expired and
they showed us bent shells and so forth
inside so it had obviously been quite a
dramatic occasion so that was the the
way we understood it a couple of weeks
later actually a surprisingly long time
later we started getting cell phone
videos of the building with snipers on
the roof well what appears to have
actually happened is not the story we
were told but the security people who
had snipers that night on much of the
buildings in Tahrir Square actually did
get into the campus go on the roof start
taking the broke the things the broken
decorative stones and stuff throwing
them into the protest
and you can see from the videos that
there were shots fired although it was
dark and so you can't tell they were
where they were firing but you have to
presume they were firing into the crowd
and apparently what happened was of
course they got there and then the
protesters broke in to try and get them
down which is why they was fighting all
the way through the building including
on the roof otherwise it doesn't the old
story doesn't really make any sense when
you think about it so in fact what
appears to have happened is that the
security forces tried to take over the
campus to use for their purposes the
protesters many of whom were AUC
students and faculty went after them got
them out and then our security risa
cured the campus and it's stayed secure
nothing else happened what's interesting
about that story is of course that you
don't get a straight story at the
beginning the security forces are our
security forces our security personnel
tell us the story which is the official
story at that time and that time Mubarak
was still in power the interior ministry
was still operating so forth and so on
and it wasn't until it wasn't until
Mubarak left that the cellphone videos
which had been taken by then ten days
earlier began to surface so there was
still a measure of fear and still a
measure of we don't know how this is
going to come out and then you start
seeing so when you think about
documenting what happened and you think
about how these stories so we started we
had out actually started before a
documentation project called University
on the square about how this took place
how it developed from the perspective of
AUC and we've been doing oral history
interviews with the switchboard operator
who was you know for 36 hours and the
bowels of the campus trying to connect
us because only landlines worked and so
they're wonderful stories like that but
there's also a kind of my little
personal obsession with information is
here it is right there we didn't get it
and we didn't get what we wanted and we
didn't get what we needed until very
late in the game so there are that sort
of it would it is hard and it is hard to
think that there were snipers on that
building shooting ended that's
not it wasn't authorized as I kept
telling people now we're now where we
are in the midst of a period where we
are
for example revisiting the policy on
expression and campus events because the
previous policy which was consonant with
the policies for all universities in
Egypt was very restrictive nothing about
politics nothing about religion and if
people unassociated with the university
want to come to a public event they had
to leave their ID card with the security
folks at the door so they could take
their names so everybody knew who was
coming and going and so forth we've now
changed that so if you want to come to
an event you show an ID card so it's
sort of orderly you keep it nobody can
take your name you just come to the
event it's if it's public it's public
you know I come from Columbia if it's
public it's public right and we've
changed you know we now have a much more
free expression kind of policy what you
would recognize in a conventional
American campus and people are really
flummoxed by that they just don't know
if you say there you can talk about
anything can you really talk about
anything can you say mean things about
Suzanne Mubarak we have a conference
room named after Suzanne Mubarak we're
having a very very interesting debate
about whether we should change the name
of the room so there are lots I mean
it's a fascinating moment to try and
move toward an institution that does
protect free expression and that people
will get accustomed over the course of
time to hearing ideas that they find
objectionable nobody's ever had that
experience before because they haven't
heard any ideas at all except the
official ideas so now they're hearing
ideas from each other they're debating
things they're arguing things in ways
that Andrew you wouldn't recognize this
but it is hugely exciting and actually
very
disconcerting and and almost frightening
sometimes for people of you know what
the what the impact of these this
opportunity to say things and debate
things and hear ideas that you really
are not sure people should be saying
those things I can say what I want but
you can't know wait if I can then maybe
you can too how does that really work
I mean it's so interesting so it's a
it's a moment where again if we do this
right if Egypt does it right if a you
see does it right it will be enormous ly
valuable because that's how ideas good
ideas are generated in debate but there
have to be places where that happens and
people have to understand that they are
in a debate they don't walk in and own
the hole they don't own the conclusion
and for a society where as with the
elections you knew how it was going to
come out before it started to enter into
a discussion where you don't know what
the outcome is going to be is a novelty
- thing about is it is that I'm 40% of
the Egyptian population is under 29 and
the revolution which is initiated by
facebook pages and to the messages the
social medias and in terms of with
capacity building after the Parliament
election scheduled in September or what
kind of opportunities and limitation do
you see for given given the Revolution
it was you know the major player for
this revolution is is youngsters well I
mean first of all I actually your
numbers are low the proportion of people
who are under 30 is probably more than
half what I really like is the people
over 60 is about 6%
including Omer Musa and you know some of
the but I don't I mean I think the
challenge is going to be taking this
energy and taking the enthusiasm and
taking the intelligence and the sort of
discipline and so forth that you see in
the group that led the uprising and I
think beyond them I mean not just there
but that generation of people the thing
that's really hard is most of them are
not employed in the fields in which they
were educated to be employed and part of
this issue of dignity is okay you told
me I could go to university you told me
I could you know major in whatever I
majored in and so forth and so on and
now I can't get a job I can't get a job
even close to that and so of is I can't
get a job at all so here I am well
educated well credentialed a respectable
person and I can't get on with my life
so I spent a lot of time blogging and
Egypt has the most bloggers per capita
of any country in the world and a lot of
the you know we used to tease about this
and obviously one of the things that was
evident to everyone is by now is that
Egypt actually also has one of the best
senses of humor in the world as you
could see from so it so but there were a
lot of people who one of the reasons why
you can have that many people stay there
for eighteen days is they're all
unemployed it wasn't as if the boss was
saying you better get back to work
which was terrific and you know creative
and inventive and so forth and so on but
it does mean ultimately the military is
right with their text messages let's go
back to work but that assumes there's a
work to go back to and that's a real
real challenge you have a population of
bright young eager ambitious people
without the kind of job opportunities
for which they believed they were
educated and it's no surprise that the
new menace
finance is actually a labor economist
that's the challenge
it is really providing an economic
environment in which these people can
thrive so I think all of the democratic
institutions and I am a political
scientist and I do think institutions
are important and so forth have to be
consonant with policies that actually
put in place the kind of job creation
and not sort of make work job creation
but things that these kinds of bright
people want to do because you saw all
the energy you saw the goodwill you saw
the kinds of things that they imagined
doing part of this I think will be to
lift the very heavy regulatory
environment in which Egyptians operate
it was very hard to start a business get
a license to do anything so forth so
there's lots of entrepreneurial activity
in Egypt but it's all informal and it's
all small-scale and it's all you know so
if you permitted that to flower and
people to be able to become formally and
officially small businesses that would
be as you saw I mean the whole top of
your square was full of small businesses
really so just let that happen so part
of it is not just job creation by having
big factories and so forth but also job
creation by incentivizing people
starting small businesses helping
develop I mean one of the things that
we're doing at AUC is a lot of running
through running people through six-week
programs in basically entrepreneurship
doing business plans how do you do a
business plan how do you do a budget how
do you get investors so forth and so on
there are lots and lots of people with
good ideas
president Anderson you made the point
earlier that I very much agree with and
probably most people in this room do
that if Egypt were to make a transition
an easy transition from to democracy um
it would be an incredible example for
the rest of the region and it would make
a really big difference one of the ways
that we judge the effectiveness of
democracy is its ability to incorporate
minority voices and we talked about the
difficulty with numbers in the region
but I believe that anywhere from 15 to
25% of the population is Coptic
Christian and one of the very few things
that Mubarak
was at all praise for was his ability to
keep a peace between those two groups
between Muslims and Coptic Christians it
seems like overall Egyptians do are very
capable of living in this diverse
environment well but there have been
some violent episodes how do you think
that the new democratic government will
be able to incorporate their voice and
if do you think that there will be
problems especially now with the Muslim
Brotherhood it's quite clear that a lot
of the leaders of the Coptic community
in Egypt are anxious about the prospect
of the Muslim Brotherhood reappearing in
any formal kind of way but I actually
think one of the most striking things of
this calendar year was the reaction to
the bombing in Alexandria and at that
point there was a huge rallying by the
Muslim population to support and protect
the Christians of Egypt they were deeply
offended by that bombing and actually
whether this is true or not doesn't
matter I'll tell you what the current
rumor mill I was talking about rumors
before many Egyptians believed that that
bombing was actually engineered by the
interior minister now departed as a way
of suggesting that there was this real
terrible Islamist al Qaeda like
terrorist threat and to both divide the
Muslims
and Christians in Egypt and to reinforce
this we're the last bulwark against
terrorism thing obviously on the ladder
well on both scores but on the ladder
score it completely backfired because
people thought it was an onion that just
not the way Egyptians deal with each
other so starting even before the
uprising you had a coming together of
Muslims and Christians around the kind
of we are all Egyptian and you saw all
the the signs with crosses and crescents
everywhere and so forth and so on
and then of course all through the
demonstrations in Tahrir Square you saw
the Christians protecting the Muslims
while they prayed and so forth and so on
and it's been a very concerted effort to
say Egypt first it's not about Islam
it's not about Christianity so forth and
so on it really is about Egypt that
obviously like everything else can fray
it could you know the cleavage between
the lower classes and the upper and
middle classes could get very fraught
the cleavage between Muslims and cops
could get very fraught there are many
opportunities for this to come apart but
I think one of the things that is quite
clear is this sort of youth age group
many of the people who are anxious many
of the cups that I know who are anxious
about this are older have a different
experience of Egypt have a different
experience of the Brotherhood have a
different experience of this sort of
sense of tension and their anxieties are
coming out coming to the fore now I
don't hear that in this the the
generation that were the animators of
the revolution I just don't hear it so
one of the interesting things is the
extent to which much of the discussion
of the dangers of the Muslim Brotherhood
in the United States in Egypt everywhere
is people of a certain age if I can put
it that way and for the young people
these are just not the same kinds of
issues I wonder if you could speak a
little bit more about the factors that
led to the fall of the Mubarak regime I
remember I had the opportunity of
meeting you last in in AUC one week
before
the real revolution started anew a
categorical about the fact that it would
never have it would never you know and
and also and and you can see if you
could if you could just talk a little
bit about what you thought you
underestimated and also you'd talk a lot
about the importance of the elites in
the in the role of the revolution but
what about the the disenfranchised
enfranchised millions living in the
slums of Cairo and and also about the
the working riots the worker strikes
rather that haven't been going on for so
long well it's actually interesting and
I commend this what I did to all of you
I wrote down when Ben Ali was exiled
from Tunisia why I thought that happened
and why I thought it wouldn't be
contagious and I did that because I
think that many of us political
scientists tend to go back and say I
knew what was gonna happen so I wrote it
down to make sure that I couldn't do
that and but but honestly my only
defense on that isn't nobody thought it
was going to happen
neither the Tunisians nor the Egyptians
in general thought it was going to
happen it did seem on implausible and
unlikely so why what why were we wrong
first of all I think we underestimated
the learning process of the people who
had been involved in April sex and March
9th and the earlier protests that failed
they learned from that they learned
organizational techniques they learned
you know sort of tactics and and a kind
of organizational intelligence that was
quite impressive
so when they saw an opportunity which
they obviously did at that point they
took advantage of it and they were as I
say they were prepared and of course the
irony is its 25th of January was police
day a perfect opportunity because you
had just seen Ben Ali you know the
problems the uprisings in Tunisia and
here was police day the reviled police
being
honored with a day of their own it was a
perfect moment to bring everybody
together because there isn't a social
class or group or anyone in Egypt that
hasn't had unpleasant encounters with
the police so that was whatever other
dividing lines there may be in Egypt
that was a common element so they saw an
opportunity in police day and they
brought people from poor neighborhoods
they brought people from areas which had
where they had never had invented Tahrir
Square in a decade and they said come on
let's come out this is an opportunity
for us to say we're sick and tired of
the police it was a very it wasn't a big
we're gonna overthrow the regime it was
we're sick and tired of the police the
police corruption the police you know
arbitrary and capricious detention and
so forth and so on and moreover we want
jobs and moreover we want other you know
so they organised a cross class across
neighbourhood and so forth in a way that
I don't think people realize they had
the capacity to do and I don't think and
honestly I don't think the day
themselves were sure that it was going
to be as remarkable as it was and once
it took the momentum then coming back
that Friday so that's a Wednesday then
coming back that Friday and so forth and
so on it could grow out of that once Ben
Ali left the idea of actually getting
rid of one of these people was alive
possibility so I think we underestimated
or a speak for myself I underestimated
the organizational capacity and the
learning of the people who did this and
I underestimated the extent to which the
kind of relief almost of being able to
say one of these guys was actually
crowbarred out of office maybe we can do
it too that turned out to be much more
powerful than I think we thought so you
know why should the Egyptians look at
look to Tunisia as an example they
typically don't but this was one of
those moments of whoa maybe we could do
it too and then it kind of took off
president Anderson thank you for joining
us here at supe my question is returning
to Egyptian foreign policy what do you
think we may expect for Egyptian policy
towards Israel in the future and what do
you believe may be the evolution of
Israeli policy towards Egypt is there
any reason to expect conflict at this
point in time I think in the short run
you're not going to see a substantial
difference in Egyptian policy toward
Israel that's what the Supreme Military
Council has said I think they're true to
their word there's not a lot of
enthusiasm for that relationship in
Egypt but there's not any particular you
know push to change it particularly
either there may be I think there
probably will be an easing of the
restrictions on between Gaza and Egypt
which I think most Egyptians think are
far too draconian and unnecessary and so
forth it's also that some things like
that may change I do think that having
the Iranian ships go through the Suez
Canal was a gesture of independence if
you will and so forth but but much of
that what that kind of symbolic politics
is probably going to be pretty much as
far as they'll go I don't think it's
gonna change very much and you know the
Israelis are quite nervous about all of
this as we know but I'm not sure they're
prepared to do anything differently
right now in light of these sorts of
changes which so I don't you know in the
next sort of rest of the calendar year
do I think things are gonna change a lot
something could happen change in Israel
and something could happen could change
in Syria in which case the dynamics but
if you're looking at it from Cairo I
don't think it's going to change that
dramatically it is possible that there
would be I think there'll be efforts to
have a different kind of relationship
with the Palestinians probably than the
Egyptians have had recently they've been
very difficult
and I think that will probably ease but
beyond that I don't think you'll see
very much so at the risk of standing
between people and the hors d'oeuvres
that are waiting for them out there I
want to ask one last question because
the security studies professors this
listserv there have been many emails
bouncing back and forth today on the
subject of what combination of military
pressure economic pressure or bargaining
inducements can be deployed to peel away
Qaddafi's circle of supporters the
factions that prop him in power given
your insights into the nature of that
regime Qadhafi has said he's going to
fight to the finish and he's gonna fight
to the finish you can't I mean he's
gonna die that's what he said he will
die as a martyr to the revolution . so
what can you do to to you know bring
some of the circle of people around him
away from him
I mean look after 40 years there are
people who are committed revolutionaries
it's not just him there are a few other
ones too who actually buy the green book
so I think there is a circle of people
who are you know they're gonna die with
them to their martyrs to the revolution
there are opportunists and again you can
see the people who switch sides back and
forth and so forth and I think what's
interesting about that is that the there
are a number of tribes particularly in
the center of the country that have
flip-flopped quite often depending on
where they think the military momentum
is and so forth I don't think you can
necessarily pry them away particularly
they'll go with whoever wins so in a
sense I don't know that there's a lot of
leverage that anybody has at this point
there's certainly nothing you can do to
change Gaddafi's behavior and the people
of his immediate circle or either his
family or his committed fervent
ideological followers and there
not much you can do about them and
everybody else will melt away as soon as
they see which way the wind is really
blowing well we were sure that this was
going to be fascinating and it was
thanks so much